well now it turns out that
two new contagious versions of
chronovirus are spreading across the
globe
hospitals aren't high alert for those
two new strains
one new variant was first detected in
the united kingdom while it's now been
confirmed in our country
in colorado california and in florida
while a second strain has been found in
south africa
all the while frustration grows over the
slow coronavirus vaccine rollout here in
our country even though it's coming
senior correspondent claudia cowan
reporting on this live in los angeles
which
has really been hit hard by covet 19.
this is certainly the epicenter hi eric
the new year is starting off with
growing concerns about these
highly contagious mutations one of which
experts say is likely spreading here in
the united states
the british strain has shown up in
colorado florida
and in san diego california where three
men who had no known contact with each
other somehow got it
bringing to four the number of cases
there and follows earlier cases
confirmed in florida
a man in his 20s with no recent travel
history
and in colorado where the governor says
health officials expect to confirm
a second case soon and he's not
surprised
there's a lot of commerce and travel
between united states and united kingdom
people go back and forth between
new york and london and san francisco
and denver and texas and london almost
every day so
it's no surprise that it wasn't kept
successfully isolated
there the cdc has joined the
investigation into how the mutant strain
got into this country
experts say that while this variant may
be up to 70 percent more infectious it
does not appear to be more dangerous or
deadly
and that people who get vaccinated
should be protected meantime officials
in south africa have confirmed the first
case of a brand new strain in a person
who arrived from
south korea on december 26th south korea
confirming they also have a patient
suffering from this brand new variant
different from the british one
and all of this coming as america's mass
vaccination effort continues to sputter
along
there were long waits in florida this
week after governor ron desantis said
anyone
65 or older could get a vaccine on a
first come
first served basis across the country
logistical problems have meant
only a fraction of the available doses
have actually been administered
so it requires strategic planning
preparation
and then you have to have funding and
without funding and really good
strong communication then we end up
seeing a delay
we've got about three million americans
who have been vaccinated but we
definitely need to pick up the pace
because that's what's going to help
save lives just under 3 million
americans have gotten their shot
the cdc says there are about 21 million
americans left to go
in the first vaccination phase eric
yeah got to get it out there claudia
thank you